the starting quarterback for the rams
the middle game on saturday may not be
available
here is jared goff from yesterday
talking about
whether or not he believes he will be
able to play with that injured thumb
i'm just continuing to feel good and get
better and continue to
heal this thumb and making sure it's
ready to go are you
in the mindset that you're going to
start on saturday
i'm in the mindset that i have to play
at any point i'm ready to play and
let's continue to press progress well
when that smile on his face tells me
he's in on the ruse that it's going to
be john walford and he's doing his best
to sell it i think it's going to be john
walford the guy just had pins
put in his thumb 11 days ago i don't
expect to see jared goff playing for the
rams
on saturday maybe if it's a disaster
with john walford
they put in an x below 100 jared goff
because they decide we'd rather have
that
than a healthy john walford but when you
look at the fact that
the rams offense is the sean mcveigh
offense it's more of a formula than it
is a gunslinger
and wilford beat the cardinals i think
if you've got jared goff at 95 90
five percent you probably are better off
with john wallford i have a feeling
peter that's what we're gonna see
you know mike uh you know that little
clip that the rams put out
last week before the game against the
cardinals
when sean mcvay is watching the inter
squad scrimmage before the season
at sofie stadium and np sofi stadium
and wolford is out there playing and the
camera's on mcvay and he says
man we got doug flutie and
i just started to think about how the
seattle seahawks are playing
right now particularly if
jamal adams plays in this game and he is
at some
semblance of 90 or better and they use
him
the way they normally use him there are
two
acquisitions from this year from
the dregs of the afc jamal adams
carlos dunlop what have they done to
this defense
especially late in the year they've made
it a
feistier more difficult defense
to play against in terms of a pass rush
and in terms of mystery blitzes
well i could see sean mcvay sitting
there right now because mike i can tell
you right now
at this precise moment sean mcveigh is
driving
to work because he leaves his house
between
4 and 4 15 to get to work so at this
precise moment
he's on his we he's he's in his driver's
seat
on the 405 near la and you know what
he's thinking
he's either already made his decision
which he probably has what he's probably
thinking is
you know i don't want to sit and duck
back there not that jared goff is a
classic
brady type sitting duck but he
i think he is thinking wolford does some
things in this game
and gets out of the pocket in this game
much better
than jared goff would i think we're
better off with wolford
i mean we see jared goff do the rollouts
and the bootlegs from time to time and
there's an ungainly quality to it
with that that uh rangy and that's the
most
complimentary word i can use physique of
jared goff and
you know what there is a chance as sean
mcveigh drives to the office he's
listening to this on siriusxm 211
in that event good morning sean and good
luck tomorrow
but i i think that's a real
consideration
to the extent and that's an excellent
point to the extent that that defense is
more swarming than it was earlier this
year
you want the guy who can get away from
it and buy some time if need be
but i don't i just don't see a
sufficiently dramatic difference that
you rushed the guy who just had surgery
11 days ago onto the field wilford won a
game built some confidence
and you see what you have in him and the
way that jared goff explained it
yesterday i get the impression he's been
told
you're the emergency option be ready to
go if we're not getting it done with
jared wolford or jared wolford
i've matched the two of them together
john wilford we're putting you
jared goff into the game flip it over to
the seahawks
because peter i went back and forth over
who to pick in this game
i think the rams could win the seahawks
could win at the end of the day though
russell wilson's 32
he only has so many swings at the bat
before he's done and i know he plans to
play another decade but we're getting
farther and farther removed from his
last super bowl appearance
the notion of losing at home in the wild
card round
to john walford and the rams i just
don't think that's acceptable
to russell wilson now whether or not
they have the offense
properly constructed to help russell
wilson carry the day is a different
issue
and the big question there is dk metcalf
versus
jaylen ramsey because we know ramsay can
handle metcalf and i think it's
incumbent on brian shot and hiring the
offensive coordinator peter
to come up with as many creative ways as
possible to get the ball in metcalf's
hands
to move him around as much as possible
to avoid jalen ramsay
where possible and ultimately ensure
that metcalf's great skills
can be utilized not running without the
ball in his hands
but running with the ball in his hands
i'm not all that concerned about uh
touches for
dk metcalf obviously you want to get it
in his hands
at least eight or ten times in the game
that's what you want to do
but i would also make this point watch
how tyler lockett is played
in this 100 reception season and watch
as the season goes on
when things get desperate
who's russell wilson looking for okay
and i'm not saying last week was
necessarily a
desperado week because it wasn't
but when he had to win a game what is he
doing
he is looking for the little sliver of a
window
to get the ball to tyler locket because
he won't drop it
he'll dive around he has become every
bit of doug
baldwin for this seattle offense and
there was a time
where i thought doug baldwin was equally
important to marshawn lynch
in the success of that offense so i look
at
seattle right now and i kind of take for
granted that
dk metcalf is going to be two catches
for 43
or something like that and and maybe
he'll score a touchdown but he won't
dominate this game
i think the solution in this game is the
secondary receivers and it seems crazy
to talk about tyler lockett you know as
a secondary receiver but
i think that tyler lockett is going to
be the key
and the solution for russell wilson in
this game
the amazing thing about this game and
sims and i talked about this yesterday
you've got
in the second game of the postseason
schedule
right out of the gates two teams that
are good enough separately to make it to
the super bowl
one is getting knocked out one is being
sent home
see you later potentially rams or
seahawks but scratch one off the list
all together
and for teams like the packers and the
saints at the top of the playoff tree
either way it's a good outcome either
way
you're happy to see one of these two
teams go because one of them can get hot
and take off and make it all the way to
tampa if uh
if given the opportunity hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports